because when you push against somebody
even the subtlest model in your head
they should be different than they are
awakens in them at a very unconscious
level pushing back
a resistance a subtle paranoia and i
have noticed in my human relationships
that as i want less and less from each
individual
there is much less paranoia in them at a
deep level and they are much more
available immediately and the
interesting thing is what does it mean
to be a safe space for another human
being a safe space means you don't have
an agenda
but we have this tendency to have a
model because we're trying to justify
the way we're living our lives
so to me that word balance is a really
key issue i mean there are so many
little balances we work with the balance
between the kind of intuitive heart and
the thinking mind
christine was saying as you get too much
thinking the energy goes up and there's
a whole contraction in the system around
thinking
and there's a tendency in the spiritual
journey to denigrate thinking to
denigrate intellect to denigrate
analytic mind and i think that we as
westerners coming out of our history of
having the intellect be the
highest power that we have and now as
we're shifting the balance it is
important that we don't throw out the
baby with a bath
and i think we are inclined to learn how
to integrate these two things so that we
can honor and delight in the beauty of
the intellect without being trapped by
it
as they say the ego or the analytic mind
is a beautiful servant and it's a lousy
master
and you can sense as you look at the
world conditions how the best of
intellect
the best of the henry kissinger's don't
solve our problems ultimately
because our problems require a different
level of
wisdom
and we have worship knowledge rather
than wisdom
and wisdom has ended a very deep
compassion
maharaji said see everyone as god
the reason i'm saying all this is
because you and i spend an
huge amount of time in interpersonal
relations
and the question i ask you since you and
i aren't going to monasteries to live
our lives since that's one of the things
we do so much wouldn't it be nice to
make it a yoga
to make your human relationships your
yoga to make your human relationships
the vehicle for becoming free rather
than the vehicle to stay entrapped
and what is required is a shift in the
way in which one looks at relationships
what they're about what their function
is we have come out of a psychological
morass
freud and all of the personality people
took us down a road
it's hard to appreciate how deep in it
we are
how deep in the doodoo of personality
how real it all is i mean you all think
you have needs that must be met
you all think you have personality
identities that must be honored
and even as i say that i can feel you
get tight
defending your right to have those
things
that
true i can feel it in myself too you
know i have a right to be angry damn
right i do
we'll wait you know there's no rush
when you finish that trip we'll still be
here
because awareness isn't in time
it's just here you want to enjoy your
neurosis enjoy
enjoy have more
have another helping really climb in
we have gotten so thick in it and so
you're either getting into it through
abuse of this or that or you spend the
rest your life getting out of it which
is all giving it that plane of reality
so much juice
and you look at your relationships from
the point of view of your separateness
how will you fulfill my needs
i'll be who you need me to be if you'll
be who i need you to be
now that kind of symbiosis is that's all
fine if you don't get trapped in it
but if you get trapped in it it's a
nightmare
it's a nightmare rooted in your sense of
separateness
it's like feeding the illusion of the
separateness which is the root cause of
the pain
so if the game is
to be happy
the question is whether fulfilling your
needs makes you happy
and whether fulfilling your needs makes
you any happier than not fulfilling your
needs it's an interesting one
it does for the moment there's no doubt
about it but if you notice that when you
live on the realm of needs the minute
one is done
another one appears you have a hierarchy
of needs so like a motivational
hierarchy i need food
now i need ice cream
now i need television
now i need a cold drink now i need some
popcorn
now i need to go to bed
if you notice that you just go from one
need to another and each one is
and then
and then
and then
it's extraordinary it's extraordinary
now these are all going on all the time
we all have needs and desires we all
have all the stuff
but just like i'm not going around being
a bald man
i am bald
relatively speaking
[Laughter]
to those of you that don't have eyes to
see
[Laughter]
but my consciousness is not full of
baldness it's an also ran
sure
in my hierarchy of desires if i have the
power yogic powers that patanjali talks
about i'll create a beautiful head of
hair for myself
as a whim i just uh
i did it on the astral plane so those of
you that can see no
and if you see the way in which people
get encrusted in their personalities you
can look at somebody and the way they
stand the way they dress the muscles of
their face the redundancy is staggering
of a person saying this is who i am this
is who they were basically saying this
is who i think i am this is who i think
i am this is who i think i am so you see
helpless people going down this is who i
think i am this is who i think i am then
you see bankers this is who i think i am
this is who i think i am
you see car salesman this is who i think
i am this is who i am
just
laid back hippies hey man this is who i
think i am hey baby this is who i am
and everybody gives you a little matrix
they're walking down the street with it
out of the doctor strange comics these
huge mine nets
and the net goes out and it catches you
and you immediately go into the
i'll make believe you are who you think
you are if you'll make believe i am who
i think i am so you don't even look to
see who they who it is you don't see
god as your only friend you don't see
that could be god in drag
you see who they think they are and you
respond to it and so everybody is going
into the personality realm making it
real and then interacting
and then looking at each other and when
you're think your personality is real
that's all you see when you look at
other people you don't see the other
planes of consciousness
i like the image of
the man in a row boat rowing through the
fog
and he hits another boat and he screams
at the other boatmen why don't you look
where you're going
and the fog clears for a moment and
there's nobody in the other boat
it was just floating
and you're left with
[Applause]
because at that moment the plane of
consciousness shifted there was nobody
there
well imagine there isn't anybody
anywhere there's only one of us that's
just awareness there's nobody who do you
talk to
can you and i enter into a dialogue
knowing neither of us are real
can we have needs without really
thinking of them as who we are where
we're living
it seems to me that we come together
through roles
through personality structures through
all these things
these are the vehicles through which we
meet these are the vehicles
the identification with the vehicle
becomes a tremendous trap and part of
the yoga of relationship
is to meet through the vehicle of all
that stuff but recognize
that through the process of relationship
my relationship with you let's find our
way
out of being trapped by that together
you help me and i'll help you
so that we can be in the roles in a kind
of celebratory
free playful way